welcome to Hannity we begin tonight with
a Fox News Alert 3 2 1 it is 9 o'clock
in the east it is 6 o'clock out on the
west coast 352 delegates are up for
grabs in six states tonight in the
Democratic primary Fox News is
projecting Joe Biden will win Missouri
and Mississippi polls have just now
finally closed in Michigan and Fox News
can make a call in that race my opening
monologue in just a minute but first we
head toward decision desk Brett and
Martha standing by with the big news hey
Jean it is 9 o'clock here in New York
and Fox News decision desk can now
project that vice president former Vice
President Joe Biden will beat Vermont
senator Bernie Sanders in the crucial
state of Michigan which Sanders won of
course four years ago it is the biggest
victory of the night for Biden who
earlier is she's just said Sean one
Mississippi
and also Missouri the Fox projection is
based on our polling of both early
voters and those who cast their ballots
today as well as data from sample
precincts we're gonna be back with
updates throughout the evening and we
will have an 11:00 p.m. roundup of all
of the election news tonight Sean as we
send it back to you all right Brett
Martha thank you we now bring in our own
Bill Hemmer now for who is gonna who's
gonna be impacted delegate wise in terms
of the delegate count you get to 15%
it's proportionate distribution of
Delegates bill what do you got that will
hemorrhage somewhere you want to hang
with me a moment here of course I do
okay all right listen I'm gonna tell you
a story okay tell you a story that I'm
seeing this race that I think is very
significant for people to understand
I'll take it in Michigan I want you to
focus on two things Sean this is right
now you're at 41% of the vote Biden
we've already called it for him over
Bernie Sanders but this is where Sanders
is underperforming and Biden is over
performing very significant - this is
Washtenaw County this is a University of
Michigan Bernie Sanders was there in
Saturday night 15,000 people
the congresswoman aoc was there as well
Bernie's at 49% over Joe Biden but four
years ago this is where Sanders was in
the same County he was at 55% he's 5%
under performing at the moment four
years later okay this is Detroit Wayne
County Oakland County is just north of
their suburbs okay critical for this
vote in the fall right we talked about
the suburbs and mission and Virginia the
suburbs out of Detroit Joe Biden is
almost at 50 percent of the vote they're
in Oakland County four years ago Hillary
Clinton was doing 51% again Biden is
over forming in some of these critical
areas in Michigan now hang with me a
moment Shawn okay because here is your
calendar in March in two weeks you have
the Georgia primary a hundred and five
delegates in two weeks next week you got
some big ones - you got Arizona Florida
Illinois and Ohio but Florida is the
biggest one of all next next Tuesday at
219 delegates well here's what we find
in terms of polling in Florida as of
today Shawn in the state of Florida Joe
Biden's clocking at 61% even if that's
not accurate
if it's close to being accurate you can
make a pretty fair argument for the
following way the race is the way the
race is shaping up today all this area
down here in the southeast we called
Mississippi for Joe Biden look what he
did in Alabama 63% of the vote there 10
days ago members Sean it was only ten
days ago South Carolina ten days ago he
was almost 50% of the vote in South
Carolina my point is you can now start
to make an argument for Georgia in two
weeks maybe Florida next week and the
whole part of this country goes Joe
Biden's way it's starting to shape up a
race in favor the former vice president
in a significant way he is outperforming
Bernie Sanders in places where he should
not if Sanders wants to catch up Sean
all right great analysis Bill Hemmer at
our big board will be checking in
throughout the evening that tells the
story tonight we'll bring you those live
updates throughout the hour as this
critical primary night does unfold as it
stands now quid pro quo Joe has pretty
much cemented its frontrunner status
over bolshevik Bernie but Joe Biden is
struggling there is no doubt in
anybody's mind everybody sees it the
media mob and Democratic Party may try
to ignore it it is now official and it
is beyond alarming if we are going to be
honest and truthful as a country frankly
it is even hard to watch the confusion
the inability to finish thoughts the
neverending daily gas the bursts of
outrage and anger should concern every
American tonight as it looks like he
will be the Democratic nominee and this
should be regardless of any political
view we now on multiple occasions he has
now forgotten Barack Obama's name he
recently confused his wife for his
sister he called Super Tuesday super
Thursday he mixed up Chris Wallace for
Chuck Todd which is an insult to Chris
Wallace he said that 150 million
Americans died from gun violence not
true he told the crowd in South Carolina
he was running for the Senate and I can
go on and on as a matter of fact well we
have examples just from the past few
weeks we have our list that's ongoing
you can read it at the side of your
screen now he cannot control his
agitation and this became apparent again
earlier today totally enraged Joe Biden
when a construction worker at an auto
plant dared to ask him about this clip
we're going to show you the clip first
because it turns out that the
construction worker at the auto plant
was right about Biden talking about
taking assault rifles here's the clip
that proves the guy is right which will
play in a second so - to gun owners out
there who say well a bind administration
means they're gonna come for my guns
bingo you're right if you have an
assault weapon the fact of the matter is
they should be illegal
period illegal period he said it so
maybe Biden again just doesn't remember
saying that he only said it in August of
2019 maybe he doesn't remember that he
recently anointed bozo beta or Roark to
lead his gun confiscation policy
remember bozo is the same guy who said
hell yes we're gonna take your ar-15 or
in Joe's case fourteenth's yes maybe
Biden doesn't remember or maybe he just
can't control his temper whatever the
case may be what I'm about to show you
should be concerning to every American
this is one incident of many incidents
that have been taking place take a look
you're fuller only problem is that
construction worker at an auto plant was
a thousand percent right his point is
valid and Joe says he's full of beep and
he wants that guy his vote and then
aggressively he SH is a staffer now
watch this part and that's not all
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
Joe Biden comparing the Second Amendment
to yelling fire in a crowded room uses
an absurd liberal talking point well all
my sons love hunting and then says he's
not trying to take away any guns when
he's on tape saying that exact same
thing which then he immediately
contradicts watch this you're a horse's
ass and all my life I thought that I
owned ar-15s I didn't know they were 14
what you just saw was the front-runner
the Democratic Party they're likely
presidential candidates shushing a woman
that appears to be on his staff by the
way who kind of seems to be trying to
help him get out of another troubling
situation great way to treat people
trying to save you from yourself Joe and
then sticking his finger in the face of
a construction worker at an auto plant
calling him a horse's ass saying that
he's full of bleep and according to one
CBC reporter on the scene Biden even
threatened to slap the man and on top of
it all well he just heard it he can't
just sit distinguish between an ar-15
and 14 I don't have 14 I have 15 staff
tried to rush him out of the roof shush
get out of the way normally maybe not a
big deal but with Joe it is now
committed Lee a huge deal this type of
agitated behavior is part of an
increasing disturbing pattern in the
past few months he's called let's see
one voter fat and a damn liar called a
young woman a lying dog face Pony
soldier and that's just the tip of the
iceberg we have tape of all of it take a
look I was a Democratic caucus yeah Ben
Dukakis no you have it
you're lying dogface pony-soldiers you
said you are but you're not you got to
be honest I'm gonna be honest with you
it's not true and no one has ever said
that and you want to check my shape
let's do we got to stop building and
replacing that go home for someone else
new campaign slogan now does that seem
like the behavior of a grounded balanced
lucid individual because Joe 303 300 or
on other occasions Joe 2 3 3 well I
better get it right
303 300 is running for the hardest the
most demanding the most powerful job in
the world there was no harder job than
meeting the President of the United
States of America so I'll ask again
does the 77 year old guy we are watching
every day now does he have the stamina
does he have the strength does he have
the focus does he have the alertness
does he have the mental folk focused the
mental toughness and even the mental
stability to be President it's a fair
question is this how he's going to treat
world leaders quid pro quo Joe kind of
looks pretty frail to me is he gonna
invite Putin to a fight or a push-up
contest or even little rocket man
because I think frankly anyone will be
able to kick his ass now it's so bad
that the Biden campaign they are now
trying to cover four quid pro quo Joe
they're trying to keep Joe out of the
public spotlight in other words they are
hiding him from the world a great
campaign strategy hide your candidate we
can't trust what he's going to do or say
this is a disaster according to the
Washington Post during his rally in st.
Louis this weekend Biden spoke for a
whopping seven minutes seven minutes oh
I could see people waiting on line for
hours to hear that and Kansas City spoke
for Wow 12 minutes and his longest
speech of the weekend it didn't hit the
15 minute mark his big rally tonight in
Ohio was cancelled after the campaign
cited coronavirus concerns although he
will speak at a separate event in
Philadelphia by the way like father like
son
there Biden he's using the coronavirus
as an excuse remember he denied
paternity in that case down in Arkansas
and now he's trying to skip out on a
child support hearing in Arkansas
because of the virus I would argue it's
probably because he doesn't want to turn
over his finances that would expose him
in the barrese McKay's and the Chyna
case and whatever other countries was
paying him Millions with zero experience
and by the way Arkansas currently has
zero cases of corona we'll get back to
quid pro quo Joe right now he cannot be
trusted to speak for more than seven
minutes by his own campaign and that
seven minutes with a teleprompter and he
wants to lead the free world
let's pause let's take that in let's
think about that now of course when quid
pro quo Joe actually does hold an event
for more than seven minutes it's a
struggle every single time a struggle is
guaranteed to ensue for example Monday's
rally in Detroit became totally derailed
after an interruption from a few
anti-nafta protesters take a look you
know I didn't are you with Donald Trump
[Applause]
there's no there's no Trump rally it's
not a truth probably let him go let's
let him go let him go the birdie bros
are here let him go
folks folks let him go that's okay
herein lies another serious problem for
quid pro quo Joe he can't hide from what
is a real horrific track record look at
your screen here are a few of Joe's top
accomplishments let's see
NAFTA disastrous trade deal Oh giving
Mosin Iran the chant death to America
yep
let's give them a 150 billion in cash
and other currencies remember Obamacare
he brags about Obamacare millions lost
the doctors millions lost their plans we
have 37 percent of the country that only
has one exchange Obama exchange care
option that's it and our premiums
average family did you save $2,500 on
average per year no we're all paying
almost 200% more and let's not forget
the horrific economic track record I
tell it off at 13 million more Americans
food stamps eight million more
impoverished labor participation rate
since the 70s then of course we had the
lowest homeownership rate in 50 years we
had the worst recovery since the 40s
more debt than 43 administration's
before them combined not a good record
compared to 8 million new jobs on the
Trump all new trade deals
we got the wall being built we got
promises made and kept on all those
trade deals and guess what America is
doing better than ever record low
unemployment for every demographic in
this country now by the way an attack
against the administration over a virus
apparently that's fair game and don't
forget that around 17,000 Americans yeah
they died from h1n1 that was the swine
flu virus that was handled you got it
under Biden Obama now Biden also voted
in favor of the Iraq war but he did an
interview and he told lawrence O'Donnell
over at MSD NC state-run conspiracy
television he did vote for a war to
prevent a war from happening he voted
for a war to make a war
from happening excuse me take a look the
reason I voted the way I did was to try
to prevent a war from happening because
remember the threat was to go to war the
argument was because Saddam Hussein had
weapons of mass destruction so he said
that I need to be able to get the
Security Council to agree to send an
inspectors to put pressure on Saddam to
find out whether or not he's jewsí as
producing nuclear weapons at the time I
said that's your reason all right I get
it that was the the rationale was that's
the way to not go to war because I
didn't believe he had those nuclear
weapons I voted for a war so we wouldn't
have a war okay now it doesn't matter
how short Biden's speeches get he can't
hide from his horrific track record he
cannot hide from the fact you're not
getting the billion unless you fired the
prosecutor investigating my zero
experience on hunter who by the way was
paid millions he can't hide the
investigation now ongoing it is
happening in Ukraine Donald Trump had
nothing to do with it it's also
happening with Senator Ron Johnson in
the US Senate and by the way how many
other millions of dollars that zero
experience hunter make there that will
be fair game in the next 238 days and he
sure as hell can hide the increasing
amount of let's be charitable senior
moments on the campaign trail and the
potential head-to-head matchup with
President Trump no stone will be left
unturned you the American people will be
the ultimate jury in 238 days you have
the opportunity to shock the world again